-President Trump confessed on TV
to the thing
he's being investigated for,
and on top of that,
he managed to drag Vice
President Mike Pence into it.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
First, let's just remember the
central issue at question here.
Trump had a phone call
with the president of Ukraine
during which he dangled
hundreds of millions of dollars
in military aid
and in return asked him
to dig up dirt on a political
opponent, Joe Biden,
by literally telling
the president of Ukraine,
"I would like you
to do us a favor."
That is extortion
and a flagrant abuse of power.
And as we said before, you never
want to do Trump a favor
because then he'll befriend you
and then humiliate you
on national television.
I mean, yesterday, all
the president of Finland did
was sit next to him
in the Oval Office
while Trump descended
into madness,
and at one point, when Trump
tried to get close to him
by putting a hand on his leg,
the president of Finland
literally had to swat him away.
-Finland is the happiest country
in the world.
-Finland is a happy country.
[ Laughter ]
-That is...
That is like...
That is like when you
get in a fight with your wife
on the drive to a dinner party,
and then when you sit down,
you try to act
like it didn't happen
but she wants you to know
she hasn't forgotten.
"Isn't that right, honey?"
"Get your hand off of me.
We will talk about this
when we get home."
In fact, during that
whole press conference,
the president of Finland
was turning to the cameras
and pleading for help
like Mr. Roper
when Mrs. Roper gets horny.
Now, as you'll recall, Trump
has lashed out at accusations
that he did anything wrong
on the call
with the president of Ukraine,
insisting there was
no quid pro quo
and that he did not pressure
Ukraine to investigate Biden.
-There was no quid pro quo.
There was nothing.
It was a perfect conversation.
There was absolutely
no pressure put on him.
There was no quid pro quo.
At all.
There was no pressure.
No nothing.
Uh, that was not pressure.
I know when I give pressure.
And that was not pressure.
-What does that mean?
"I know when I give pressure"?
Trump's only defense is,
"I know when I commit a crime,
and that was not a crime."
Like if the cops
knocked on your door and said,
"Did you beat a guy to death
with a tire iron,
chop up his body
with a chain saw,
and throw his limbs
into the river?"
And you said, "I didn't chop him
up. I know when I chop guys up."
You might also remember
that in addition to the actual
notes from the call,
we also have
the whistleblower's complaint
which has been deemed
urgent and credible
and alleged that the President
pressured Ukrainian
President Zelensky
to initiate or continue
an investigation
into the activities of former
Vice President Joseph Biden
and his son, Hunter Biden.
And even though we've literally
seen the call notes
and Trump has basically
admitted to doing
what the whistleblower alleges,
he also keeps calling
the whistleblower
a liar and a spy.
In fact, he even claimed that
once House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
saw the actual notes
from the call,
she changed her mind
on impeachment.
-The whistleblower
was so dishonest.
The whistleblower said
terrible things about the call,
and if you remember
at the beginning,
it was "quid pro quo."
That's all you heard about.
And I think he said seven
or eight times "quid pro quo."
In other words,
you're gonna do that
or we're not
gonna give you money.
You're gonna do this,
or we're not gonna --
Nancy Pelosi called for
essentially impeachment.
"Let's impeach the President."
Before she saw the transcript.
So when she saw that, she --
I heard she went crazy.
She said, "We can't impeach him
in this conversation.
That's a great conversation."
[ Laughter ]
-I guarantee you
she did not say that.
At this point, he's just writing
fan fiction
about Nancy Pelosi now.
"Nancy Pelosi
walked into her office,
and she read the transcript
and said,
'We can't impeach him!
We can't impeach him
on this conversation.
That's a great conversation.'
And then she gazed
out the window
and had the same thought
that had nagged her for years.
Why hadn't she married someone
as handsome as Donald Trump?"
[ Laughter ]
So, again, all of this --
all of this is confirmed
by the call notes themselves.
We already have
all the evidence.
It's all there in plain sight.
But yesterday, a reporter tried
to ask Trump a simple question.
If you weren't pressuring
the president of Ukraine
to investigate Joe Biden,
then what were you
asking him to do?
And instead of answering
that question,
Trump got mad and told him
to talk to the president
of Finland instead.
-Go ahead. Ask a question.
-The question, sir, was what did
you want President Zelensky
to do about Vice President Biden
and his son, Hunter?
-Are you talking to me?
-Yeah.
It was just a follow-up
of what I just asked you, sir.
-Listen. Are you ready?
We have the president
of Finland. Ask him a question.
-I have one for him.
I just wanted to follow up
on the one that I asked you.
-Did you hear me?
Did you hear me?
Ask him a question.
-I will.
-I've given you a long answer.
Ask this gentleman a question.
Don't be rude.
-He's like a teacher
telling his class
to listen to his guest speaker
on Career Day.
"Look.
I know Kyle's dad is boring
because he's an accountant,
but you got to ask him
a question.
Kyle's right there.
He's super upset about this."
So, to recap, Trump said
there was to pressure,
no quid pro quo,
the whistleblower was wrong,
and he did not -- he did not ask
the president of Ukraine
to investigate Biden.
And then this morning,
he told reporters
on the White House lawn
that he wanted Ukraine
to investigate Joe Biden.
-What exactly did you hope
Zelensky would do
to Hunter Biden
after your phone call?
-Well, I would think that
if they were honest about it,
they'd start a major
investigation into the Bidens.
It's a very simple answer.
They should investigate
the Bidens.
I would say that President
Zelensky, if it were me,
I would recommend
that they start
an investigation
into the Bidens.
[ Laughter ]
-So -- So he just
confessed on TV.
After two weeks
of lying and spinning,
he just admitted
to the crime he's accused of.
He basically just blew
the whistle on himself.
He should have a whistle just
around his neck at all times.
"Ukraine should investigate
Joe Biden."
[ Whistle blows ]
"Putin should find
Hillary's e-mails."
[ Whistle blows ]
"I'm gonna release a sex tape."
So Trump has once again just
outed himself as a criminal,
but as we all know,
when Trump implodes,
he doesn't just implode
on his own.
He takes everyone else in
the White House down with him.
Trump's like a tornado.
You don't know when or where
it's going to touch down,
but when it does, it's going to
suck up some cows, a few houses,
and maybe even a scarecrow.
And we're seeing the same thing
happen in the Ukraine scandal
that sparked
the impeachment inquiry.
For example, you might remember
last week when out of nowhere
Trump dragged
Vice President Mike Pence
into his mess
by telling the press
that Pence had also spoken
with the president of Ukraine
and that they should look
at Pence's phone calls, too.
-I think you should ask
for V.P. Pence's conversation
because he had a couple
of conversations, also.
I could save you a lot of time.
They were all perfect.
Nothing was mentioned
of any import
other than congratulations.
But the word is that
they're going to ask
for the first
phone conversation.
You can have it
any time you need it.
And, also,
Mike Pence's conversations,
which were I think one or two
of them -- they were perfect.
-And let me just say,
with all sincerity,
no one deserves to be
dragged down by Donald Trump
more than Mike Pence.
Although, Pence is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pence should have seen
this coming...
when Trump tried to give him
a "Godfather" kiss
at the RNC in 2016.
"Come here, Fredo.
Come here, Fredo."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then after Trump
dragged Pence into his mess,
you'll never guess
what happened.
"The Washington Post"
did some reporting,
and it turns out
Pence also had a phone call
with the president of Ukraine
where he discussed cutting off
the hundreds of millions
of dollars in military aid
that Trump had dangled
as part of his quid pro quo.
-"The Washington Post"
reports President Trump
repeatedly involved
Vice President Pence in his plan
to exert pressure on
the new president of Ukraine.
Trump used the Vice President
to inform the Ukrainian leader
that hundreds of millions
of dollars in U.S. aid
was still being withheld.
-Well, Mike Pence,
you can't be surprised
that the ass [bleep]
you pledged your loyalty to
is now throwing you
under the bus.
This isn't a case
of the carriage turning
back into a pumpkin, because
he's always been a pumpkin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And on top of that,
on top of that,
White House sources are clearly
leaking to "The Washington Post"
that Pence was involved
so they can dirty him up, too.
I love imagining
how this is all playing out.
Pence coming home
from a hard day's work
of trying to blend in with the
background during meetings,
flicking on the lights,
and the house is empty
except for Trump
sitting there in the corner
with his back turned.
"Ohh.
Hello, Mike.
Weren't expecting me, were you?
Oh, you're in trouble, Mike.
It's all --
It's all here in this note.
I know what you did last summer
because I did it, too."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, if you read --
if you read this
"Washington Post" article,
you can almost see,
line by line, Pence's aides
trying to claim he's innocent
and White House aides
claiming he's guilty.
Pence's aides, for example,
say they didn't know anything
about Trump's efforts to
pressure Ukraine's president
to investigate Biden.
Officials close to Pence
insist he was unaware
of Trump's efforts
to press Zelensky
for damaging information
about Biden and his son.
All right, I'm sorry,
but that's just insane.
Of course Pence knew about it.
You think Trump
kept this a secret?
The guy can't keep his mouth
shut about anything.
He probably ran over to Pence's
office immediately to tell him
about it just like a kid
who figured out
how to type "BOOBS"
on a calculator.
"Mike! Mike, look.
Do you see, Mike?
Mike.
Mike. Mike.
Do you see?"
[ Laughter ]
So, obviously,
Pence knew what was going on,
just like Trump's
Secretary of State, Mike Pompeo,
who was on this call, and his
Attorney General, Bill Barr,
who was named repeatedly
during the call.
So now,
because they're all implicated
and because
they have no defense,
they're just threatening to
block the impeachment inquiry
all together. Trump's calling it
a treasonous coup,
and Rudy Giuliani is actually
threatening to sue Congress
for following
the impeachment procedure
laid out by the founders
in the Constitution.
And if you're wondering just
how serious this lawsuit is,
here's a real
text-message exchange
Rudy had with a reporter
for "The Atlantic"
who posted it to Twitter
on Tuesday.
"What are you planning
to do next?"
"Looking at a jawsuit
to end lawless action."
"Who are you going to sue?"
"The swamp.
Trump v. the swamp."
"How do you sue the swamp?"
"In federal court."
You know it's bad when "jawsuit"
isn't even the stupidest part
of the text message.
Seriously, why are these guys
so bad at spelling?
Yesterday, Trump spelled "moat"
with two O's.
Rudy spelled lawsuit "jawsuit."
In fact,
if you showed up at court
and told the judge you wanted
to file a "jawsuit"
against impeachment,
they would call it moot
and then dismiss it
like the president of Finland.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Again, what happened here
is very simple.
The President
extorted a foreign country
to meddle in the 2020 election,
his staff tried to cover it up,
and then they got caught,
and now he's admitting to it.
Several of his most senior aides
are involved, and they're
threatening to obstruct
the impeachment inquiry.
And, most importantly, the Vice
President is now involved, too.
Trump is turning on Pence,
and all Pence can say is...
-Don't be rude.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]